Kyle: ..and we're best friends.
Arianna: Yes, we are.
...and he just kind of
gets along with everybody.
Kyle: I don't get along with
everybody as well as...
...as well as I get along with you.
but it's true though
I feel like I've known you...
for....ever
Arianna: This feels like a family.
You know what I mean?
I think the
Spanish and Portuguese Department
has a very interesting way of
making it feel like this is home.
Alison: My friend Gaby Molina
we both went on this program
the summer after freshman year....
..didn't know each other beforehand.
And we got really close then
and kind of went through the process...
sophmore year of deciding to
major in Spanish together.
...and I just remember we'd keep meeting up
for lunches, and we each had our
respective alternative majors
and just kept talking
ourselves closer to Spanish.
Until it came time for declaration day
and we're both like
"wait, like I think
we're both going to do it.
I think we're both
going to do Spanish."
I'll always remember all of the
crazy memories that I've had
both abroad and in the Spanish Department.
Whether it be climbing up the mountain
in Barcelona to go interview
a radical Catholic nun.
Or eating rice and beans with strangers
that I recently met in Cuba.
Or walking along the
trails of Machu Picchu.
Or even going to Prospect House and
having a really good meal with
a TA or Professor.
So in terms of how
"SPO" has helped me
I like to direct alot,
and I'm interested in
theater that matters.
Political theater.
And for my thesis
I've gotten to study Political Theater in Brazil
under the dictatorship.
and actually being able to connect
a country that I really I love
with a shared artistic heritage and passion
has been really really
important in thinking about
what matters for me moving forward.
So, I'm kind of hoping to continue
studying some teatro do oprimido -
theatre of the oppressed
The fact that I've just been able to
go to anarchist dens in
the outskirts of Madrid
and also home studios in Havana
has been something I wouldn't
have expected I would be doing necessarily...
but it's very important for me in my
overall intellectual and personal growth.
I think that my favorite
memories were actually
with my independent work.
My advisors that I had really
guided my academic experience here
in a way that I hadn't expected.
And sort of like empowered me to....
I don't know.
I hadn't really thought of myself as an academic
before my independent work.
And having someone recognize it and say like
"This is actually good. You're actually
thinking pretty differently about the field"
was a big deal.
We went to see the Iguazu Waterfalls,
which is the most amazing thing I've ever seen.
Standing on the edge of one of
the world's biggest waterfalls
as the water tumbles over
and we're just watching
beautiful rainbows cascade about.
I think we were all really awestruck
and it put a lot of things into context.
So that was an amazing moment.
I think the best memories that I made were
actually the friends that I met
in Buenos Aires in my research
were all from Spain because
they were studying abroad.
And I got to see them when
I went back this January.
So, that was really cool to
kind of complete the circle
and maintain contact with
those friends I met abroad.
The thing that sticks out
in my head is just like...
a Spanish Department reception
at Palmer House with...
Kyle: DJ Max Grear.
Arianna: Yeah [Laughing]
Kyle: And people dancing and I don't know.
Kyle: What other department are people
going to be dancing Salsa for hours?
Arianna: Yeah...with their professors!
Kyle: With their professors. Yeah!
Thank you everybody for an awesome
four years here at Princeton.
I really appreciate your
friendship and your teaching.
Boa sorte. O melhor de tudo para vocês.
Obrigado por tudo.
Pues estoy súper agradecida por todo lo que
me ha dado el departamento de español.
De verdad ha sido una experiencia fenomenal y
si lo pudiera repetir, lo haría sin falta.
Y muchísimas gracias a Alberto,
que siempre ha sido una persona
que me apoya en todos los
momentos que lo he necesitado.
De verdad te voy a echar de menos… a todo el departamento.
Han sido cuatro años espectaculares.
Muchísimas gracias
por todo, de verdad.
Felicitaciones a todos mis amigos.
Y muchísimas gracias a todos los profesores
por darnos una experiencia increíble;
y por siempre, siempre,
darnos oportunidades
que no podríamos tener
en otra universidad.
Kyle: Caetano Veloso, the Brazilian Singer,
has a song "Alegre"
which is like "joy".
Its a bit ironic, but, I would say
lets take it!
Like, Alegre! In this moment. I don't know.
Arianna: Yeah.
Congratulations to the rest of the
strong Spanish Class of 2018.
There are a lot of us and we did it!
We're almost there.
Enhorabuena.